is the single biggest uh attack on
record and of course so much of this is
shrouded in secrecy
normally but the numbers are staggering
in this uh attack and we can't say we've
not had warnings about infrastructure
attacks in the last couple of months
certainly here in the us
uh a big attack on a meat processing
plant that supplied a fifth of america
the attack on the uh petrol pipeline
that supplied most of the east coast and
now this one
now this was an attack on the software
of a few dozen
firms but those few dozen firms manage
remotely the i.t
infrastructure for thousands of other
companies and it's those other companies
that have been paralyzed by this along
with those other
those few dozen companies uh financial
services
uh travel and leisure companies uh
business retail businesses for example
have been paralyzed uh by this and and
the the hackers initially were demanding
um ransoms a few thousand for the
smaller firms a few million for the
bigger firms they changed that yesterday
to a demand for 70 million dollars
in total to release everything the
feeling being that this had even taken
them by surprise they didn't expect it
to go this far
uh when they when they set out with this
and they simply want it over but
again the focus is on on russia we know
most of these ransomware attacks emanate
from
russia that appears to have happened
again in this case
um now and we know that joe biden raised
this issue with with vladimir putin
at their summit in geneva joe biden
saying vladimir putin need to do
something about this
either russia was directing these
attacks or was certainly tolerating them
in the mind of the russian president or
the u.s president and that attacking
critical infrastructure was was
unacceptable and was in no one's
interest so
the pressure is on the usa they will
respond to these these attacks they're
still investigating this one but a
reminder again of that that
vulnerability that exists and just how
damaging
these these attacks can be okay greg
thank you